my father always said follow your
heart's direction it's the best driver
you've got what's going on
Lucas Prince is what's going on he is
graciously agreed to oversee the
renovation of this beast of the house
let's start the tour I can't wait to get
my hands dirty figuratively of course
what I'm wondering
I should appear can I take you out
tomorrow night you are simply magic so
much we're going to make her forget
everything and everyone at the money the
company you will wake up in a motel you
will not remember your inheritance you
will run away and never come home again
[Music]
let me introduce you to the booth that's
Z that's true nanny
Oscar Tim this is doc we need someone to
come right here make this place feel
like home now then you build on too long
[Music]
hunter as long as true love does not
cross her path the deal is done
we dislike everything really
I knew I would find you I have no idea
who you are most eligible bachelor
architecture digest ring any bells
there's somebody here who's telling me
I'm missing big chunks of my life
miss earnest James I just don't
understand the appeal of this jolly
Commons holidays whatever Victoria's
gonna steal all of my bed money and my
company
we have to stop it
[Music]
only one thing maybe remember all of
them
[Music]
please have a seat
this is so sweet of you Victoria
anything for you when I plan parties I
believe you should be surrounded by
things you love and make you happy makes
you happy well people make me happy
perfect what else I like simple things
really simple makes you happy
think of one of your favourite Christmas
birthdays ah well my dad and I got out
of the city good what else for we stayed
in a cute little hotel a simple motel 3
hi I need to cancel two plane tickets to
Fiji we always made hot chocolate
because your father couldn't afford
anything else - nothing fancy
you don't like fancy
and one you will wake up in a motel the
only things you will remember are the
simple things you love to do with your
father you'll want to live in this town
you wake up in you will not remember
your inheritance you will be content in
your new world
you will run away and never come home
again
you